if we take a look in in the past we got
a true window into your personal life
Chelsea we got to see you having babies
and starting your family getting married
to Cole really just your personal life
and now you're on a show where it seems
like that might be taking a back seat
and we're really gonna put the spotlight
on what you do as a career so what has
been the biggest change for you with how
you filmed the previous show with how
you're filming the current show to save
it the hugest weight
has been lifted off my shoulders like
isn't even I can't even describe it
enough like I feel so proud of the show
and to share the show and I like there
was times that I would be so nervous
about
Teen Mom earring just because I'd be
like guilty did I share too much did I
share something that should have been
kept personal to my kids or something
like that and I just I don't feel that
at all I just feel proud and you still
do get to see a little bit of the kids
but I feel like it's very you know
light-hearted so this is like the best
of both worlds I feel like okay so if
you had to slap a percentage on it Cole
how much personal are we gonna see and
how much work are we gonna see
probably
95 work well it's a kind of a mixture
but yeah there's a mixture and it's not
like personal it's personal because it's
us and it shows our family but not like
deep diving into like before I was like
going to a doctor's appointment yeah
you know you get to see our family but
it's not you know us sitting down having
a conversation about
what's going on you know but I feel like
with this show we were actually people
get to see how we really are and our
true personalities you were able to to
make this really challenging transition
from one series to another what do you
attribute this massive achievement to
my dad always said to take the high road
you know and he always like gave me
advice like it always pays off to be a
good person and
that's it there was times where I
definitely did not want to take the high
road and I wanted to like
get down and dirty but I just always
remember what he said and was a good
person and I do think that that paid off
like I think the choices I made I always
was trying to look out of how like I
could be a good mom and a good person
and I do think that that contributed you
know is just being a good person and
making smart decisions as a human being
um I think really did pay off in the end
we laughed about how you were nearly a
30 year old woman at the time and you
were still on the show called Teen Mom
yes yes right I think a lot of people
still consider or think of us as being
these young or Teen Moms did you see the
one where someone said to keep my legs
closed or something I was like
I mean I'm married so it just cracks me
up do you feel like that Teen Mom label
has finally been put to rest
and it was so funny recently there was
like some kind of article and they
referred to us as the HGTV couple get it
yes instead of Teen Mom and I like sent
it to goal I was like oh my God this is
huge let me just chime in too when I
would tell like you know my manly
friends or my old construction
colleagues be like oh you're on a TV
show I'm like
um we don't need it talk about the title
of what it is but you know but now I
would like to be on Asian TV it's like
hell yeah right as you reflect though on
that chapter that you put to bed Chelsea
is there anything you regret is there
anything you miss
um no I don't regret anything like it's
just so I haven't like gone back and
watched anything and I kind of want to
someday but it just was I think it was
important part of my life obviously like
I'm so grateful for it and it got this
platform and everything happens for a
reason this is all Stepping Stones you
know that led us to where we are and I
truly truly believe that
um but also like I feel really good
about when we left and how we laughed
and if I miss anything it's the people
because you become so close with the
camera crew and like your producer and
stuff like that and we still keep in
touch so that would be the one thing and
and speaking of people I commented on
your Instagram this morning and I
couldn't help but notice one of my other
favorites Leah Messer she left you a
very supportive
who are you still in touch with from the
Teen Mom world I still am in touch with
a couple of them they've been so
supportive like you saw like commenting
or sending like private messages and I
just think that's so sweet because like
we we did go through that together and
we are still very supportive of one
another and I want them to smash it and
do amazing and I think they want the
same thing so and I don't I think kale
laughed shortly after but it's scary
it's leaving that show was scary because
it was [ __ ] and all that I knew for
how many years but I think
I mean I hope they're happy in it if
they're still on it and if they're not I
hope they
feel confident in seeing us you know
transition and feel like they can do the
same okay so you're in touch with Leah
you're in touch with kale anyone else
not really I mean there's maybe like
nice like replies to like Instagram
stories but
there's not there's no one that I have
bad feelings with okay we'll just keep
it positive at that
we have this design business showing
clients how to take risks and go bold
with their design I'm the designer and
I'm the project manager Dream Team
oh
down home Fab your new HGTV show how are
you feeling
you know what's crazy is usually I feel
like I would have so much like anxiety
or I'd be so nervous but I just feel so
excited yeah I'm very excited I'm very
proud of all the work we did and very
proud of how all all the homes turned
out so I'm excited Chelsea for you I'm
curious because you know you jumped from
one show to another was it always the
plan to get back to television or did
you think when you said goodbye to your
last chapter that maybe you were done
with TV for good yeah there was no plans
at all like I fully left teen mom
thinking like you know that's probably
it hmm
but I was okay with that also like I
just felt like that's fine
um so the fact that this all happened
after like closing that door was just
kind of it's been a wild ride I never
thought that we would make the
transition from you know Teen Mom which
is so different these are completely
different TV shows you are in the
company of the El moussas the Property
Brothers chip and Joanna like have you
met any of these people no fan out over
them I mean we haven't met them but I
would probably fan out the other day
there was like a commercial and it was
just like a collage of all the shows
coming out or something this year and it
was all like the ogs and then we were
kind of sprinkled in there and we were
literally jumping up and down our living
room like oh my God now I I know that
the show is called Down Home Fab and I
believe you coined the term South Dakota
Glam that is your aesthetic can you
explain to me what does that exactly
mean yes it's almost like a mixture of
being cool like Cole brings like The
Rustic Vibes you know he's like an
Outdoorsman I'm an old soul and I love a
good Glam moment I like you know all the
makeup the cute clothes and stuff so our
our style is a lot of like
cow hides and antlers but also mixed
with like big gold light fixtures so we
just kind of coined at our South Dakota
Chic or South Dakota Glam as our our
Style the real running theme Here seems
to be the two of you as a power couple I
love that it's So Meta you are working
together as you design home renovation
partners then take it a step further
you're now filming a television show
together and you're married to each
other so we've got like three levels
there what is it like truly spending 24
7 together mixing the business with the
pleasure
you know I feel like a lot of people it
wouldn't work for them
um right and probably a lot of people
think we're crazy and that we would end
up fighting or hating each other but
honestly I feel like we rely on each
other I I rely on her for so many
different things and I feel like without
her it just wouldn't be the same so if
we are on two different parts
in one day I'm always like texting him
I'm like wait
like we make everything fun it doesn't
matter what it is even if like we're
working or doing something that's not
fun we just make it fun and if I'm like
just if I'm destroying something or
working on something I want to impress
her so if it's just there's always it
sure comes off yeah you know did you say
the shirt comes off because sometimes it
does sometimes it does you gotta give
her a show called I mean I got an
attractor right
I cannot wrap my brain around the fact
that aubry's 13. what is it like raising
a teenage daughter I mean you get
something new every day uh I don't think
someone new every day yeah someone
that'd be probably a better someday for
the mood she loves us you know some days
she cannot stand us so I think you know
you you just take it day by day you
don't really know how to plan you just
saying she's like become our social
media helper yeah right because she
always is like you guys should make this
tick tock
listen I love seeing her pop up in your
tick tocks but I tried looking she
doesn't have her own account is that
right no we are the mean parents we
won't allow certain social medias and
she just thinks we're the worst for that
I think my biggest fear would be like
any kind of room comment because I mean
you can't control what people say you
know there's always going to be those
people and that just terrifies me I feel
like as a young as a young teenage girl
I don't want her to see anything
negative in effect her her in any way I
want her to just you know especially
because she's not your average teenage
girl she's been on TV for yeah her whole
life so I tried it still that in her and
say you know your friends haven't
exactly grown up on TV so it's kind of
hard to yeah but she doesn't get that
she's like you know it's like you guys
are mean I'm just being protective is
all I'm doing I swear we joked the last
time that we spoke I was like do you
think your family is complete at this
point or I mean sky's the limit Are You
Gonna Keep expanding well as of right
now I feel like this Baby's gonna
complete our family but I mean who knows
like in five years maybe you will get a
wild hair but as of right now it feels
like complete how do you guys feel about
that statement today
we say yeah the door is not closed but
the door is also not open it's just crap
it's craps we don't know because I still
might think we we might get a wild hair
can't say no
you know listen with this Empire that
you're building to me it feels like the
more the merrier yeah same well right
because you know down the line it's just
pre-employment right there we got free
employees
[Music]